and some people or some Swedish people
know all of them because I cannot
generalize I met some of them they were
very good people and so on what I said
is not a lie it is true even the
Christians are speaking out against your
governments and by the way I'm not
blaming every person that works in the
government of course because Islam teach
us Justice no oppression it's known that
Swedish Social Service are known not all
of them again but generally speaking and
they are known to take the Muslim
children and to even the children openly
saying we have no problem with our
parents and they still take them away
from them to brainwash them and to give
them to to people that have not been two
of them so stop kidnap kidnapping the
Muslim children and even the Christian
children recently the Christian Arabs
are speaking out against you and let me
tell you something called Sweden don't
think you have welcomed the refugees
from Syria because you love them because
you're getting the money from the United
Nations so the money you're giving to
them is not from your own pocket stop
complaining and that money from the
United Nations is coming from our
countries from the from the Arab
countries on the gulf Kuwait other
countries so stop complaining because us
you making money when you accept
refugees and Assad and Seekers then
United Nations giving you money so you
utilize them to make money all right so
that's how we teach you Abdullah